yes and when welcome to this video
playing bones Frank let's go
let's see usually goes d5 see sixth
against this in g6 on way now sorry he
takes and then plays a g6 base setup if
I remember correctly yeah this is some
super solid setup obviously for black I
think that white is a little bit better
but it's not it's not serious by any
means so a five let's put it here
quickly choice a little bit strange but
I'm happy that I've got the bishop here
on the diagonal I can trade against g7
if he moves the light
let's go G for you
hmm I'm surprised
I mean the Queen cannot stay on default
for a long time but it's our turn now to
avoid the Queen trade and this chief I
stuff is I think we can black a little
bit
easy decision
and now 94 c5 is is the next plan
so he lets me take it that's interesting
you will take b2 at the end but the
remaining c6 pawn looks extremely
extremely weak our be Twitter is an
active square I mean
okay now if deaf this is a waste of time
I should have taken this who this of
much quicker at the end I will I will
take anyway it's just like it is just
the principal move to play so what did
you thought about the whoopsie I am III
probably Knight b3 doesn't really do
much
just for that night before so how do we
play t 4d 4b should be one rupee one
something like that
d4 bishop reforms are a default we
should be form group b1 something like
that maybe when you place without a
bishop on the age
hmm yeah that's true that's definitely
true can try this
I can also try light a 4 and Luke c5
Knight info is actually threatening King
D to trapping the rook that took me a
long time to see but this is this is
very strong how does he actually keep
the rook yeah
the look is strapped how does he keep it
Knight b6 maybe try to get an exchange
at least in absence
Knight b6 I probably playing a b19 a for
p8 and should win pretty easily
yeah that I don't see a defense
you
taking in the noise yes
also d5 is hanging
[Music]
yeah but if I go King you one should
check C 5 and D 5 and bold hanging
time warning
94 I was still still very annoying
actually check we look at the check
check check
black for six long time
I know I'm good panic to the day at the
end of because I was thinking the game
would be over already and then he saw
somehow continued so and yeah we have
this opening I think this is a little
bit more comfortable providing I cannot
much but I'd rather be whitey in this
position
Queen h4 yeah and I don't know if this
is really that great yeah the engine
gives black an advantage this is kind of
funny I don't I don't think so I just
don't think so
I mean I think I'd rather have white
because of the more compact bone
structure and I've got an additional
center pond I know probably equal but I
mean you saw that it didn't didn't take
a long time to give me an winning
advantage here okay whoop th jump here
and this this was probably not a good
idea
they should just even want to take home
so night before seems to be the move
here
I'll just network a 300 is amazed it is
equal with this maybe if 6% is Sonia
maybe I don't have anything concrete
them ok take away night before yeah this
is a blunder it's really a blunder do
tonight a forum which took me a long
time but I didn't yeah didn't see it at
first okay yeah there was some panic
decisions but I think all in all I'm
okay with with the play there with no
time on the clock okay guys thanks for
watching